Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The sun never shone on a cause of greater worth. It is not the affair of a city, a county, a province or a kingdom, but of a continent, of at least one eighth part of the habitable globe. It is not the concern of a day, a year or an age. Posterity are virtually involved in the contest and will be more or less affected
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。太阳从未照耀过一个价值更崇高的事业。这不是一个城市、一个县、一个省或一个王国的事情，而是一个大陆的事情，它至少占了人类可居住地球八分之一的面积。这不是一天、一年或一个时代的事情。后代子孙实际上也被卷入了这场争端中，并且或多或少地会
even to the end of time, by the proceedings now. Oh, ye that love mankind! Ye that dare oppose not only the tyranny but the tyrant! Stand forth! Every spot of the old world is overrun with oppression. Freedom hath been hunted round the globe. Asia and Africa have long expelled her. Europe regards her like a stranger, and England hath given her warning to depart. O receive the fugitive, and prepare in time an asylum for all mankind. So that, Dominic, was son of East Anglia, Tom Paine, radical, enthusiast for revolution, and specifically in this context, author of pamphlet Common Sense, which came out in January 1776. And we've got Adam Smith with us. Adam, am I right in saying
受到现在所采取的行动的影响，直到永远。哦，你们这些热爱人类的人！你们这些敢于不仅反对暴政而且反对暴君的人！站出来吧！旧世界的每一个地方都充斥着压迫。自由在地球上四处遭到追捕。亚洲和非洲早就驱逐了她。欧洲视她如陌路，而英格兰则已经下达了逐客令。哦，请接纳这位逃亡者，并及时为全人类准备一个庇护所。所以，多米尼克，他是东盎格利亚之子，托马斯·佩恩，激进主义者、革命狂热分子，在当时的具体语境下，他是 1776 年 1 月出版的小册子《常识》的作者。我们身边还请来了亚当·斯密。亚当，我说得对吗？
that this is really the first kind of mass market pamphlet that argues for removing America's links with the British monarchy? It was genuinely a bestseller, genuinely a bestseller. And it was subsidised and it was circulated across all of the 13 colonies. And it was, as you say, the first pamphlet to explicitly and clearly make the case not only for independence, but a positive case for republicanism. So, hello, everybody. Just to give you a bit of context, if you're just tuning in, this is the third in our series on the American Revolution. We have had the Boston Tea Party. We've had the Battle of Bunker Hill. The colonies have been declared by George III as being an open revolt and we are now in january
这确实是第一本主张切断美洲与英国君主制联系的大众市场小册子吗？它确实是一本畅销书，名副其实的畅销书。它得到了补贴，并在所有 13 个殖民地广泛流传。正如你所说，它是第一本明确而清晰地不仅为独立造势，而且为共和主义进行正面辩护的小册子。那么，大家好。为了给大家提供一些背景信息，如果你刚刚收听，这是我们关于美国革命系列的第三集。我们经历了波士顿倾茶事件。我们经历了邦克山战役。乔治三世已经宣布殖民地处于公开叛乱状态，现在我们来到了 1776 年
1776 for the publication of this extraordinary pamphlet half a million copies of adam i think it's sold by the end of the year and thomas pain is actually the irony is he's not actually american so he's gone to america but he is as tom's exquisite uh impression suggests he's from thetford in uh in norfolk and he used to make corsets, I think. I think that was in Sussex. He moved to Lewis. To make the corsets in Lewis? I believe so, yes. Okay. Well, and he'd been twice been sacked as a customs officer, ironically,
1 月，这本非凡的小册子出版了。亚当，我想到了年底它卖出了五十万册，而托马斯·佩恩，讽刺的是，他其实不是美国人，所以他去了美洲，但正如汤姆精妙的模仿所暗示的那样，他来自诺福克的塞尔特福德，他以前好像是做紧身胸衣的。我记得那是在萨塞克斯。他搬到了刘易斯。在刘易斯做紧身胸衣？我想是的，没错。好的。嗯，而且他曾两次被海关开除，讽刺的是，
for incompetence and corruption, I think. So are you a big Thomas Paine fan, Adam? I'm not really, I have to say, Dominic. I do admire the muscularity of his prose. And common sense is you can see why it was so effective. It doesn't have all the Latin tags and all the learned references that most of the pamphlets of the American Revolution did. Whenever I think of Thomas Paine, though, I think about what happened to his body after he died. Do you know this story? He died in obscurity. And of course, he was very unpopular by the end of his life, including in America. But his great British admirer, the radical William Cobbett, went to America and brought back his body to England, hoping that his admirers in England would create some kind
我想是因为无能和腐败。那么亚当，你是托马斯·佩恩的超级粉丝吗？说实话，多米尼克，我算不上。我确实很欣赏他散文的力度。你可以看出《常识》为什么会如此有效。它没有美国革命时期大多数小册子中那种拉丁语标签和博学的引文。不过，每当我想到托马斯·佩恩，我就会想到他死后他的尸体遭遇了什么。你知道这个故事吗？他在默默无闻中死去。当然，到他生命快结束时，他非常不受欢迎，包括在美洲。但他伟大的英国崇拜者、激进派威廉·科贝特去了美洲，把他的尸体带回了英格兰，希望他在英格兰的崇拜者能在他周围建立某种
of great tomb around it. He couldn't raise the money to do so. So kind of very Lenin behavior. So he kept the bones of Thomas Paine in a box in his house. And when he died, they were sold with his effects. And nobody knows what happened to them. And there's some of them, some bones have turned up in Australia quite recently. And there's bits of Thomas Paine all over the world. So poor old Thomas Paine ended badly even beyond his life. But you probably didn't want me to quite go there. No, that's great. To go back to common sense. I mean, this has a massive impact, right?
宏伟的陵墓。他没能筹集到足够的资金。所以这有点像列宁的行为。于是他把托马斯·佩恩的骨头放在家里的一口箱子里。当他去世时，这些骨头连同他的遗物一起被拍卖了。没有人知道它们去了哪里。最近在澳大利亚出土了一些骨头，一些骨头。托马斯·佩恩的碎骨散落世界各地。所以可怜的托马斯·佩恩即使在死后也以悲剧收场。不过你可能并不想让我扯得这么远。不，这很好。回到《常识》。我的意思是，这产生了巨大的影响，对吧？
Yes, it really does. And he is the author of these resonant phrases. And you read some of them out just then, Tom. The cause of America is the cause of all mankind. I mean, that's not only is that a great phrase, that is, in many ways, it seems to me the key to understanding American political culture. That what happens in America, the cause of this revolution, everything we do in America, our purpose is transcendental meaning. We are providentially blessed in some important way the cause of america is the cause of mankind what happens here has universal significance but when when it comes out is there a sense in which as well as enthusing the revolution uh inspiring kind of an upsurge of backing for republicanism. Are there also conservatives among the revolutionaries who
是的，确实如此。他正是这些掷地有声的短语的作者。汤姆，你刚才还朗读了其中的一些。“美洲的事业就是全人类的事业”。我的意思是，这不仅是一个伟大的短语，而且在许多方面，在我看来，它是理解美国政治文化的关键。美洲发生的事情，这场革命的事业，我们在美洲所做的一切，我们的目的都具有超验的意义。我们在某种重要意义上得到了神明的保佑，“美洲的事业就是全人类的事业”，这里发生的事情具有普遍的意义。但是当它出版时，除了激发革命热情、鼓舞人们对共和主义的支持之外，是不是还有这样一种感觉？
become a bit nervous about this, who kind of pull back from... John Adams, for example, doesn't like common sense at all. He thinks he's badly argued based on abstractions. John Adams is a serious man who thinks that the business of government and constitution writing, which he loves, I mean, thinks that the business of government and constitution writing, which he loves, I mean, he likes the business of constitution writing, but he thinks it's a serious business of balancing interests. It's not about all this kind of blue skies thinking, these grand abstractions. And he thinks it's very dangerous, the direction that Thomas Paine is going, including the practical suggestions that Paine is making
革命者当中是否也有一些保守派开始对这个感到有点紧张，开始从……比如，约翰·亚当斯一点也不喜欢《常识》。他认为它基于抽象概念，论证得很糟糕。约翰·亚当斯是一个严肃的人，他认为政府事务和宪法起草——这是他所热爱的，我的意思是，他认为政府事务和宪法起草——这是他所热爱的，我的意思是，他喜欢宪法起草工作，但他认为这是一项平衡各方利益的严肃工作。这并不是关于所有这些不着边际的空想、这些宏大的抽象概念。他认为托马斯·佩恩前进的方向非常危险，包括佩恩提出的那些实际建议
about how a republic, once you've overthrown the king and the British empire, should look. And John Adams doesn't want the debtors and the poor farmers in the western parts of the states to be running these new independent states, should it come to that. So there's a lot of nervousness as well as enthusiasm. And before we get into Adams and what happens next, to go back to that thing of the cause of America is the cause of all mankind. At this point, does the rest of mankind care? I mean, are people watching? I mean, there's always that sort of sense in America, isn't there, that the world is watching. I mean, it's been chanted so many times by protesters, demonstrators through American
关于一旦推翻国王和大英帝国，共和国应该是什么样子。约翰·亚当斯可不希望各州西部地区的债务人和贫苦农民来管理这些新独立的州，如果事情真的发展到那一步的话。因此，除了狂热之外，也有很多紧张情绪。在我们探讨亚当斯和接下来发生的事情之前，回到“美洲的事业是全人类的事业”这一点上。此时此刻，世界其他地方还在乎吗？我的意思是，人们在关注吗？我的意思是，美国人总是有这样一种感觉，好像全世界都在看着。我的意思是，在整个美国历史中，抗议者和示威者曾多次高呼这一点
history, the eyes of the world are on us, the shot heard around the world. But is the world watching at the beginning of 1776? It's a good question. And I think often the answer is that a lot of the world anyway is watching. And that's why they're often right to say that the eyes of the world are upon us, which is the John Winthrop phrase from the 17th century, which was being revived at a right about this time or a little bit later, that what happens here matters. And there were always at this time and later and earlier, plenty of people outside of America, people who'd never been there, people who dreamed of America, who projected onto America a kind of vision of the good society, who wanted America to be the future. And what Paine was saying in common sense were the sorts of things
历史，“全世界的目光都在注视着我们”，“响彻世界的枪声”。但是在 1776 年初，全世界都在注视吗？这是一个好问题。我认为通常的答案是，无论如何，世界很大一部分都在关注。这就是为什么他们通常有权说全世界的目光都在注视着我们，这是 17th 世纪约翰·温斯罗普的名言，大约在这个时候或稍晚一点被重新提起，这里发生的事情很重要。当时、之后以及之前，美国境外总是有大量的人，从未去过那里的人，梦想着美国的人，将一种美好社会的愿景投射到美国身上、希望美国成为未来的人。佩恩在《常识》中所说的话正是这类话
that radicals in Britain had been saying for years. And the attacks on the king, which were quite crude and extreme, but which were the sorts of things that you would hear in radical circles in Britain in the 1770s. So the royal brute calling him that kind of, yeah. And to go back now to the sort of military strategic picture, the British had been in Boston, but they basically realized they can't, they're trapped in Boston, they have to get out.
英国的激进分子多年来一直在说的话。对国王的攻击相当粗俗和极端，但这些话你在 1770 年代的英国激进圈子里是绝对能听到的。所以称他为皇家野兽这种，是的。现在回到军事战略的大局上，英国人曾驻扎在波士顿，但他们基本上意识到自己无法做到，他们被困在波士顿了，必须撤离。
So a couple of months after Paine publishes that pamphlet, General Howe, William Howe, who is the commander in Boston, says, okay, out. And they evacuate the city completely. I mean, the city that's been the cockpit of revolution. They take some of the loyal, several thousand loyalists with them who they dump in Halifax in Canada. And then they come down and establish themselves in New York. New York, which we haven't mentioned really at all, actually, in the preceding two episodes. But New York, which has a, I mean, I don't know anything about this period at all, but is New York a more loyal city than Boston? Yes. Yes, it definitely is. And there are certainly, there's a stronghold of loyalism
所以在佩恩出版那本小册子几个月后，波士顿的指挥官威廉·豪将军说，好吧，撤。他们完全撤出了这座城市。我的意思是，这座曾是革命风暴眼的城市。他们带走了一些忠诚派，几千名忠诚派，把他们扔在了加拿大哈利法克斯。然后他们南下，在纽约建立了自己的基地。纽约，我们在前两集里其实根本没有提到过纽约。但是纽约，我对此期历史一无所知，纽约比波士顿更忠于英国吗？是的。是的，绝对是的。纽约肯定有一个忠诚派的据点。
in New York. It's not a straight, but there had been some conflicts with the New York legislature earlier on over the Quartering Act and things. So it's not quite as straightforward as that. But certainly the British had reason to believe that if they wanted to create a beachhead, then New York was a good place to do it. Also, because it, of course, is at one end of the Hudson River Valley. So the idea was, if you can send a force down from Canada, from Quebec City, and up from New York and control the Hudson Valley, then you cut off New England. And there's still this notion that New England is the problem. So if you cut them off from the rest of the colonies, that would be a good strategic move to make. So that's another reason why New York is the focus at that point in 1776.
这不是一个直接的问题，但早些时候纽约立法机构在《驻军法》等问题上确实发生了一些冲突。所以事情没有那么简单。但毫无疑问，英国人有理由相信，如果他们想建立一个滩头阵地，那么纽约是个好地方。此外，因为它当然位于哈德逊河谷的一端。所以他们的想法是，如果你能派出一支部队从加拿大魁北克城南下，从纽约北上，控制哈德逊河谷，那么你就能切断新英格兰。人们仍然有这样一种观念，即新英格兰是问题的根源。因此，如果你将他们与其余殖民地切断，这将是一个明智的战略举措。这也是为什么纽约在 1776 年那个时候成为焦点的原因。
But while the British are sort of working out what their strategic plan is going to be, their authority is pretty much collapsed across the colonies. People aren't listening to their officials. People have set up their own town committees of safety or whatever. And the Second Continental Congress is still going. That's right, isn't it? And they are where? They are in Philadelphia now. Yes. And they are busy with the business of government. They have no formal authority to do so, but they are communicating with the colonies who are often now already being referred to as states and saying, you've got to get your house in order, set up a independence or not? But most of the business of the Second Continental Congress up until this point is just preparing for war and trying to keep the business of government going. But that's the key thing, isn't it, which I hadn't properly appreciated, is that with the collapse of British rule and without the announcement
但正当英国人在制定战略计划时，他们在整个殖民地的权威已经基本瓦解。人们不再听从他们的官员。人们已经成立了自己的城镇安全委员会或类似机构。第二届大陆会议仍在召开。没错，是这样的，对吧？他们在哪儿？他们现在在费城。是的。他们正忙于政府事务。他们虽然没有这样做的正式权力，但他们正在与殖民地（现在通常被称为“州”）进行沟通，并对他们说：你们必须整顿好内部，建立独立与否？但在此之前，第二届大陆会议的大部分工作只是在为战争做准备，并试图维持政府的运转。但关键就在于此，不是吗？我之前没有充分认识到这一点，那就是随着英国统治的崩溃，在没有宣布
of a kind of new state to replace it, everything is in limbo. Tax collection, the entire functioning of government. And John Adams, who I keep on invoking, I quite like John Adams really, and he's fundamental in some ways, quite a conservative figure. And his view at the beginning of 1776 is basically, thank goodness that independence has been, our independence has in practice been declared by the British government, referring to the Prohibitory Act at the end of 1775, which prohibited all trade, the whole of the 13 colonies, that isolated all the 13, extending the coercive acts from Massachusetts to the whole of the colonies. I mean, for Adams,
用一种新国家来取代它的情况下，一切都处于悬而未决的状态。税收、整个政府的运作。约翰·亚当斯——我一直在提到他，我其实挺喜欢约翰·亚当斯的，他在某些方面至关重要，是个相当保守的人物。他在 1776 年初的看法基本上是：谢天谢地，我们的独立实际上已经由英国政府宣布了，指的是 1775 年底的《禁运法案》，该法案禁止了所有的贸易，针对全部 13 个殖民地，孤立了所有 13 个殖民地，将针对马萨诸塞州的强制法案扩大到了所有殖民地。我的意思是，对亚当斯来说，
that was effectively the British government saying, you are now on your own and we are at war with you. It was them, the British government, that took that initiative. So everything thereafter from John Adams' point of view was merely reactive on the part of the rebels. Because he's conservative and he doesn't want to do anything so subversive as to declare independence himself. Yes. I mean, by this stage, he thinks a formal declaration of independence is certainly going to happen eventually. And he's keen to think of what a constitution will look like in that new state. But he is pleased that, as it were, not just the first shot, but the declaration of war has come as he understands it from London and not from the colonies. And he's not wrong to think
这实际上等于英国政府在说：你们现在只能靠自己了，我们在跟你们打仗。是他们，英国政府，采取了这一举动。因此，从约翰·亚当斯的角度来看，此后的所有行为都不过是叛军的被动反应。因为他很保守，不想做出宣布独立这样具有颠覆性的举动。是的。我的意思是，到了这个阶段，他认为正式发表独立宣言迟早会发生。他热衷于思考那个新国家的宪法会是什么样子。但他很高兴，不仅是第一枪，而且宣战的决定正如他所理解的那样来自伦敦，而不是来自殖民地。他这样想并没有错
that because declaring a blockade is an act of war. And that is what the British government does at the end of 1775. But there are more radical figures. I mean, we've talked about Paine, but there are more radical figures who are actually American. And I guess the most celebrated of these is Thomas Jefferson, who is the man who will write the first draft of the Declaration of Independence. So what has he been up to in the build-up to the war? And then what is he doing in the summer of 1776? Jefferson is a very interesting figure. The closest the American Revolution comes to kind of Robespierrean figure, although in a way that's rather flattering to Jefferson, makes him more of
因为宣布封锁就是一种战争行为。这就是英国政府在 1775 年底所做的事情。但还有一些更激进的人物。我的意思是，我们谈到了佩恩，但还有一些更激进的人物是地道的美国人。我想其中最著名的就是托马斯·杰斐逊，他将起草《独立宣言》的初稿。那么他在战前一直在忙些什么？然后在 1776 年夏天他正在做什么？杰斐逊是一个非常有趣的人物。他是美国革命中最接近罗伯斯庇尔式的人物，尽管在某种程度上这对杰斐逊来说是一种奉承，使他比实际情况更像一个
a man of action than he probably was. I mean, he was a very privileged Virginia planter, slaveholder, who thought of himself as an intellectual, a man of the Enlightenment, a cosmopolitan figure steeped in the new ideas and convinced that he and his generation, and he certainly felt himself to be the head of his generation, had an opportunity which had rarely, if ever in human history, come before. An opportunity to, in a painite way, begin the world anew, to start a new page and reinvent what it meant to be human. And he loved talking in these kinds of ways. And many people find that very inspiring. And he was a great wordsmith. And we see that in the preamble to the Declaration of
行动派。我的意思是，他是一个特权阶层的弗吉尼亚种植园主、奴隶主，他自认为是一个知识分子、启蒙运动的代表人物、一个沉浸在新思想中的具世界主义视野的人物，并且坚信他和他的同代人——他确实觉得自己是同代人的领袖——拥有一个人类历史上绝无仅有的机遇。一个以佩恩的方式让世界重新开始、翻开新的一页并重新定义“何为人类”的机遇。他喜欢用这种方式高谈阔论。许多人觉得这非常鼓舞人心。他是个伟大的文豪。我们在《独立宣言》的序言中就能看到这一点，
Independence, which is obviously a beautifully written, sublime document, rightly famous and revered over the last 250 years. The quality of his prose was exceptional. And why is it Jefferson? So first of all, well, why did Congress decide they need a Declaration of Independence? I mean, because there are some people aren't there i think new york maybe delaware some of the colonies are a little bit more dragging their heels about it don't think it's the right thing to do well because i was amazed that by the first of july only nine of the 13 states have basically signed up to the separation from britain i think it was the second of j July that the motion was passed to formally constitute these new... guns, bells, bonfires, and illuminations from one end of this continent to the other. Whereas in fact, it's the Declaration of Independence, of course, on the 4th of July that is celebrated. He says Americans celebrate the press release rather than the act itself.
这是一份显然写得极其优美、崇高的文件，在过去的 250 年里一直享有盛誉并受到尊崇。他的文笔非常卓越。为什么偏偏是杰斐逊？首先，好吧，为什么国会决定他们需要一份《独立宣言》？我的意思是，因为有些人不是吗，我想纽约、特拉华州，一些殖民地对这件事有点拖泥带水，认为这不是一件正确的事情。好吧，因为我很惊讶，截至 7 月 1 日，13 个州中只有 9 个州基本上签署了与英国的分离协议。我想是 7 月 2 日通过了正式组建这些新……从这块大陆的一端到另一端，到处都是枪声、钟声、篝火和烟花。然而事实上，当然是 7 月 4 日的《独立宣言》受到了庆祝。他说美国人庆祝的是新闻稿而不是行动本身。
Yes. I mean, it's a very good question. Why do they need a Declaration of Independence? Declaration de facto already existed. In Thomas Jefferson's mind, that had been the status quo ante anyway, as we've talked about in previous episodes. Well, you need all the states together, though, don't you? I mean, you need all the states to agree because otherwise they can be picked off much more readily if they haven't signed up to a kind of central declaration. Yeah. And the press release, as you call it, or as Woody Holton calls it, is important because it's a manifesto. It's a statement of principle,
是的。我的意思是，这是一个非常好的问题。为什么他们需要一份《独立宣言》？事实上宣言已经存在了。在托马斯·杰斐逊的心中，这本来就是既成事实的状态，正如我们在前几集里讨论过的那样。不过，你需要所有州团结在一起，对吧？我的意思是，你需要所有州都同意，否则如果没有签署某种中央宣言，它们就会更容易被各个击破。是的。你所谓的新闻稿，或者伍迪·霍尔顿所说的那样，之所以重要，是因为它是一份宣言。它是一份原则声明，
and it's a justification for what they're doing, aimed in no small part at Paris. At this point, the Americans knew that if they were going to engage in what they imagined would be a difficult and potentially long military engagement with the British, they were going to need support from France. So it was a kind of justification, which was necessary for diplomatic purposes, but internally within the United States. And the key thing about the Declaration of Independence and what makes it new is that it is the king that's the target of the grievances. It's not parliament. And it had to be the king. It had to be the king it had to be the king because by this point they were attempting to secede from the british empire up until this point they had been saying we can be effectively a self-governing dominion within the british
它是对他们所作所设所为的辩护，在很大程度上是针对巴黎的。当时，美国人知道，如果他们要卷入他们想象中与英国人之间艰难且潜在漫长的军事冲突，他们将需要来自法国的支持。因此，这是一种出于外交目的所必需的辩护，但在美国国内也是如此。独立宣言的关键之处以及使其成为新事物的地方在于，它是将国王作为申诉的目标。而不是议会。而且必须是国王。必须是国王，因为到了这个时候，他们正试图从大英帝国分裂出去。在此之前，他们一直说我们实际上可以成为大英帝国境内一个自治的领地，
empire and therefore we will still owe loyalty to the king in july 1776 they were saying no no no we we are going to create our own empire. And that was often the word that was used. And that was always the word that was used in London, creating their own empire, American empire. So therefore they had to throw off allegiance to the king. And therefore it was necessary for them to turn King George III into this tyrannical figure, necessary in order to justify to the world as well as to themselves what they were doing, just as in the same way it had been necessary in the 1640s for the parliamentary side to focus on the king in the end and why it was necessary for the king to die in the 1640s in order to
因此我们仍然效忠于国王。而在 1776 年 7 月，他们说：不，不，不，我们要建立我们自己的帝国。这也是当时经常使用的词。这也是伦敦一直在使用的词，建立他们自己的帝国，美洲帝国。因此，他们必须摆脱对国王的效忠。因此，他们有必要将乔治三世变成这样一个暴君形象，这不仅是为了向世界、也是为了向他们自己证明他们所做的事情是正当的，就像 1640 年代议会派最终不得不把矛头对准国王、以及为什么在 1640 年代国王必须死以证明他们所做的事情是正当的一样。在宣传方面，
justify what they were doing. And in propagandistic terms, isn't the effect of that of proclaiming itself a republic as opposed to a monarchy, it's backward looking because they can then invoke the Roman example, the Roman Republic that expelled its king, and it can draw on all that kind of classical language, elevating freedom and liberty and virtue. But it's also, I think you could use the word progressive without too much risk of anachronism that it's signing itself up to the more progressive element the more radical element of the enlightenment and identifying america the new world as a kind of you know the best hope for humanity that it
把自己宣称为一个共和国而不是君主国，难道不会起到一种回顾过去的效果吗？因为这样他们就可以援引罗马的先例——那个驱逐了国王的罗马共和国，并且可以借鉴所有那种古典语言，来颂扬自由、解放和美德。但同时，我认为你使用“进步”这个词也不会承担太大的时代错位风险，即它认同了启蒙运动中更进步、更激进的元素，并将美洲这个新世界确定为一种（你知道的）人类的最佳希望，它已经挣脱了枷锁，再次成为山巅之城，为旧世界树立榜样，
has cast off the chains that once again it's a city on a hill offer an example to the old world exactly and that liberty has has fled from its yeah so back to the pain comments has fled from england and has taken up refuge in the new world exactly so adam i mean his different historians have different takes on this so for example gordon wood he's written lots about how the language of the declaration the language of the revolution in fact is rooted in the what he sees as the what lots of historians see as the kind of country oppositional tradition, which is a kind of itself an attempt to preserve what people see as the good old cause of 17th century England. So there's that, but there's also the Enlightenment and let's say the French Enlightenment, Voltaire,
正是如此，自由已经从英国逃离，并在新世界找到了避难所，完全如此。所以，亚当，不同的历史学家对此有不同的看法。例如，戈登·伍德，他写了大量关于宣言的语言、实际上也是革命的语言的文章，认为这些语言植根于他以及许多历史学家所看重的乡村对立传统之中，这本身就是一种试图保留人们心目中 17th 世纪英格兰美好旧事业的尝试。所以有这一点，但同时也有启蒙运动，比方说法国启蒙运动，伏尔泰、
Montesquieu, these characters, and there's John Locke and so on and so forth. So which of these traditions do you think is, can we say which is the more important? Well, I mean, there's also absolutely the biblical traditions that are deriving from the Puritan and the Quaker inheritance as well. Tom, absolutely. I mean, but the rights of man, the fact that the creator endows human beings with rights.
孟德斯鸠这些人物，还有约翰·洛克等等。那么你认为这些传统中哪一个更重要，我们能下定论吗？嗯，我的意思是，绝对还有源自清教徒和贵格会传统的圣经传统，汤姆，绝对的。我的意思是，人权，造物主赋予人类权利的事实。
Even though a lot of them are deists, aren't they? But that idea is being framed in a way that can appeal to both Quakers in Philadelphia and Puritans in New England, but it's clearly very biblical. So Adam, untangle some of those strands for us. The Declaration of Independence itself is clearly Lockean. It's making a Lockean argument about the social contract, that it has been broken, and that's the core justification for setting up a new government. And this is not
尽管他们中的许多人都是自然神论者，对吧？但这个理念的构建方式既能吸引费城的贵格会教徒，又能吸引新英格兰的清教徒，但它显然非常具有圣经色彩。所以，亚当，请为我们梳理一下这些不同的线索。《独立宣言》本身显然具有洛克的色彩。它提出了关于社会契约的洛克式论点，即契约已经被打破，这是建立新政府的核心理由。而且这不是
accidental. I mean, not just Jefferson, but these other elite figures gathered together in Philadelphia had read these tracts, or at least knew enough about them to be able to speak competently about them. They could least knew enough about them to be able to speak competently about them they could do a podcast about them they could definitely do a podcast about them yes they knew how to fake it uh and so i i mean yeah i don't know how i i mean if you if you're just asking about that document itself it's easy to read it in those enlightenment uh thinkers dominic and the broader pamphlet literature, and this is where Gordon Wood and his mentor Bernard Balin is making this argument about the Whig country
偶然的。我的意思是，不仅是杰斐逊，还有聚集在费城的其他这些精英人物都读过这些小册子，或者至少对它们了解足够多，能够自信地谈论它们。他们至少对它们了解足够多，能够自信地谈论它们，他们甚至可以围绕它们做一期播客。他们绝对可以做一期播客，是的，他们知道如何假装内行。所以，我的意思是，如果你只是在谈论那份文件本身，很容易从那些启蒙思想家身上解读出来，多米尼克。而在更广泛的小册子文学中——这也是戈登·伍德和他的导师伯纳德·贝林提出关于辉格党乡村传统和 17th 世纪美好旧事业论点的地方，他们不仅在研究《独立宣言》，而且在研究前 15 年发表的所有小册子，
tradition and the good old cause of the 17th century, they're looking at not just the Declaration of Independence, but all of the pamphlets published in the preceding 15 years, and they're looking at all and they're seeing, what they're seeing in that language is the 17th century and early very early 18th century english language of liberty whiggish language of liberty and so what that does is to give to the revolution a functioning state i mean even if very still inchoate but also a kind of ideology that people can now increasingly sign up to and which gives a kind of motivational
他们正在研究所有这些小册子，并且在其中看到的语言是 17th 世纪和 18th 世纪初英国的自由语言、辉格党的自由语言。因此，这赋予了革命一个运转中的国家——尽管仍然非常初级——以及一种人们现在可以越来越认同的意识形态，从而为他们的行动提供了某种动机上的辩护。是的。“我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的：人人生而平等。”《独立宣言》序言中的这行字，当然经常被引用为美国的意识形态基石。除此之外，这也使得将美国项目视为一个意识形态项目、一个致力于特定理念的项目成为可能。这实际上是亚伯拉罕·林肯的用法，对吧？林肯在 1863 年的葛底斯堡演讲中将《独立宣言》——他不是唯一这样做的人——变成了这个国家名义上的洗礼文书，
justification for what they're doing. Yes. And we hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal. That line from the preamble to the Declaration of Independence has, of course, frequently been cited as effectively the ideological underpinning of the United States. And that is what makes it possible among other things, but that's the core of it, to think of the American project as an ideological project, a project that is dedicated. And this is actually an Abraham Lincoln usage, right? Lincoln and Gettysburg in 1863 turned the Declaration of Independence, he wasn't the only person to do it, but he turned the Declaration of Independence into this baptismal document for the nation,
而不是《邦联条例》、《宪法》、《巴黎条约》或国际法中的任何其他东西，而是因为那段激动人心的序言，所以选中了《独立宣言》。当然，马丁·路德·金在 1963 年也引用了它来谈论平等。正如金在 1963 年华盛顿大游行中所说的那样，这是一张“本票”。我们来这里是为了兑现支票。
not the Articles of Confederation or the Constitution or the Treaty of Paris or any of these other things in international law, but the Declaration of Independence because of that rousing preamble. And of course, Martin Luther King in 1963 will also invoke it to talk about equality. A promissory note, as King calls it. We've come to cash the check, as he says
但是，亚当，这就说到点子上了，不是吗？“人人生而平等”的那个主张，他们当中有些人其实并不真心相信。杰斐逊一生拥有 600 名奴隶，而在他有生之年，我记得他只解放了两个。所以华盛顿满嘴都是别人的牙齿。我的意思是，这是 21st 世纪对他们的批评。
in the March on Washington in 1963. But Adam, that goes to the point, doesn't it? That claim we hold that all men are created equal, some of them don't mean it. Jefferson himself has 600 slaves in his lifetime, and during his lifetime, I think he freed two. So Washington has a mouth full of other people's teeth. I mean, this is the criticism that is made of them in the 21st century.
我们上次谈到了《1619项目》等等，有人会说《独立宣言》是一份保守的文件。但多米尼克，这也是当时就有人提出的批评。我的意思是，我们在上一集中讨论过约翰逊博士。所以，亚当，他们原本有一段关于奴隶制的段落，但被删掉了。是这样吗？是杰斐逊自己写的然后又删掉的吗？
We talked last time about the 1619 Project and so on, that the Declaration of Independence is a conservative document, some people would say. But Dominic, it's also a criticism being made at the time. I mean, we talked about Dr. Johnson in the previous episode. So Adam, they had a section on slavery, which they cut out. Is that right? That Jefferson himself wrote and then cut out?
我想在杰斐逊的原稿中，这绝对是所有指控中最长的一段，其中一些指控略有倾向性，所有的指控都有些夸大其词。那是罪状中最长的一条，谴责国王将奴隶制强加给殖民地。这一段被大会给删掉了。没错。《独立宣言》确实可以说是美国历史上最具有重大意义的文本，正如伍迪·霍尔顿所说的那样。因此，我认为我们花时间进行如此详细的探讨是值得的。但我们必须记住，与此同时还有一场战争正在进行，
And I think it was by far, in Jefferson's original draft, it was by far the longest of the list of grievances, some of which are slightly tendentious and all of which are slightly hyperbolic. That was the longest one, the one condemning the king for imposing slavery on the colonies. That was cut out by the convention. Right. The Declaration of Independence is really, in a way, the single most significant text, parche, Woody Holton in you know, in the history of America. So I think it's worth looking at it in the detail that we have done. But we must remember that there is simultaneously a war going on,
而我们几乎还没怎么谈到它。那我们现在为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，一起来看看战争的进程以及正在发生的事情。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。战争的进程以及正在发生的事情。购票请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 restis》。我们刚才一直在讨论《独立宣言》，国会在 7 月 2 日投票赞成独立。两天后，就是我们刚才说的新闻稿，费城钟声齐鸣，大炮轰鸣。几天后，乔治·华盛顿在纽约向他的军队宣读了独立宣言，他们拉倒了乔治三世的雕像。当然，我的意思是，这提醒我们，正如汤姆在休息前所说的那样，战争正在进行。
which we've barely touched on. So why don't we take a break now? And when we come back, let's look at the course of the war and what is going on. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. of the war and what is going on. live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So we've been talking about the Declaration of Independence, which Congress votes in favour of independence on the 2nd of July. Two days later, it's the press release, as we were saying, and there are bells ringing in cannon going off in Philadelphia. A few days later, George Washington reads the declaration to his troops in New York and they pull down the statue of George III. But of course, I mean, that's a reminder that there is, as Tom said just before the break, a war going on.
因为他们把雕像熔化了，不是吗，把它铸成了子弹。确实如此。完全正确。是的。甚至在他们这么做的时候，3万名英国军队——我相信这是有史以来派往海外规模最大的欧洲军队，这让你大概能体会到英国所面临的挑战的规模。3万名英国军队正在斯塔滕岛登陆。英国人说：去他的波士顿。波士顿不重要了。现在的当务之急是纽约。亚当，我说的对吧？
Because they melt it down, don't they, and turn the statue into bullets. They do indeed. Exactly. Yes. And even as they do that, the 30,000 British troops, which is, I believe, the largest European force ever sent overseas, which gives you a scale, I suppose, of the challenge that is facing Great Britain. 30,000 British troops are coming ashore on Staten Island. And the British, so they've said, sod Boston. Boston is gone. The priority now is New York. That's right, isn't it, Adam? which was functionally the capital of this newly declared independent country or nation or whatever it was or empire. And they knew they had a formal opponent in the Continental Army under the command of George Washington.
纽约实际上是这个新宣布独立的国家、民族或帝国的功能性首都。他们知道他们在大陆军中有一个正式的对手，由乔治·华盛顿指挥。他们有理由相信，不仅仅是因为邦克山战役，他们不应该轻视这个敌人。但在这个时候，其他一切仍然处于变动之中：这将会是一场什么样的战争？海军能够发挥什么作用（如果有的话）？能从保护世界其他地方的英国殖民利益中调配多少资源？最终这会有多重要？为了支付在北美的又一场战争，英国的税收还要涨到多高？所有这些在 1776 年都还有待决定。
They had reason to believe, not least because of the Battle of Bunker Hill, that they shouldn't underestimate this enemy. But everything else was really still in flux at this point. What kind of a war this was going to be? What role, if any, the Navy was going to be able to play? How much resource could be diverted from the protection of British colonial interests elsewhere in the world? How important in the end was this going to be? How high were taxes going to go in Britain yet again in order to pay for another war in North America? All of these things were still to be determined in 1776.
那么关于英国人，有两个问题。第一个问题是，他们甚至在这个阶段就已经意识到法国和西班牙可能会插手了吗？是的。这是他们最大的恐惧。当然，国王和诺斯勋爵无论如何都不想失去这 13 个殖民地。这涉及到巨大的自豪感、虚荣心、爱国主义以及所有这些类似的情绪。但这里存在着一种基本的关乎地缘政治的焦虑。他们以前打过那场非常成功的战争——
And so two questions about the British. One is, are they conscious even at this stage that the French and the Spanish might pile in? Yes. That is their big fear. Of course, the King and Lord North, they don't want to lose the 13 colonies anyway. There's a huge issue of pride and ego and patriotism and all these kinds of things. But there is a basic geopolitical anxiety. They previously fought this highly successful war,
七年战争，把法国人赶出了北美，这里显而易见的危险是，这将为法国人重新占领他们在北美的部分或全部前殖民地提供机会。因此，他们必须留下一部分军队。他们可能需要防范法国对英国本土的入侵，他们还必须防范加勒比地区。他们在两种情况下都需要这样做，因为——我的意思是，真正的担忧是加勒比海岛屿的失守。当然，在 17th 世纪后期法国参战后，确实存在着遭到入侵的真实威胁。所以他们的这种想法并没有错。那么我的第二个问题非常简短：英国国内是不是有些人认为，
the Seven Years' War, expelled the French from North America, the obvious danger here is that this is going to provide an opening for the French to repossess part of their or all of their former colonial possessions in North America. So they have to keep some troops back. They have to defend Britain from French invasion, conceivably, and they have to defend the Caribbean. They need to in both instances because there is, I mean because that's the real worry is the loss of the Caribbean islands. And of course, there is a genuine threat of invasion after the French enter the war in the late 1770s. So they're not wrong to think that. So my second question very quickly is, are there some people in Britain who think,
好吧，现在及时止损吧，事情已经成了定局，这行不通了，我们取消这一切吧？我的印象是，实际上相当一部分高层指挥官都是这么想的。很多人都是这么想的。查塔姆勋爵，也就是前威廉·皮特，基本上就是这么想的。这也是国王现在面临的问题之一，那就是国王真的致力于镇压这场叛乱。他能与之合作以实现这一目标的唯一首相就是诺斯勋爵。所以当诺斯勋爵一再表示，我再也应付不了这个了，
okay, cut our losses now, the thing is gone, this has not worked out, let's call the whole thing off? I mean, the impression I get is that actually quite a number of the high command think that. A lot of people think that. And Lord Chatham, former William Pitt, basically thinks that. And this is one of the problems that the king now has, is that the king is really committed to suppressing this rebellion. And the only prime minister he can work with to achieve that goal is Lord North. So when Lord North keeps on saying, I just can't cope with this anymore,
求求你，求求你，在下一届议会会议结束时让我辞职吧。然后国王一直说不，因为他知道唯一的选择就是邀请某个反对派派系领袖，而他们的政策将是和平政策。那么，关于乔治三世——他在这个故事的大部分内容中都莫名其妙地缺席了——在此时此刻，乔治三世真的算是一个关键因素吗？因为他的顽固，（你知道的）你可以称之为他的爱国主义，如果你愿意的话，或者他的小写c保守主义，或者他的自豪感，这真的成为了让英国人继续战斗下去的一个因素吗？是的，我认为是的。我认为确实如此。而且我认为这正是正确的表达方式，
please, please, please let me resign at the end of the next parliamentary session. And then King keeps on saying no, because he knows that the only alternative is to invite one of the opposition factional leaders whose policy will be a peace policy. So just on George III, who's oddly been absent from almost all the story, at this point, is George III genuinely a factor in that he is his stubbornness, his, you know, you can call it his patriotism, if you like, or his small C conservatism, or his sense of pride, that that is, is that really a factor in keeping the British fighting? Yes, I think it is. I think it is. And I think actually that's the right way of putting it,
多米尼克，因为直到现在，讽刺的是，国王并不是一个主要的参与者。很显然，他并不是真正掌控政府政策的人。他只能通过内阁来实施政策。他极其注重宪法特权和先例。但他非常、非常、非常坚信绝不能允许美国人获得独立。因此，他非常努力地为他的内阁大臣们打气。所以他在其中确实是一个因素。那么对英国人来说，问题在于：他们到底要怎样才能夺回美洲？因为他们赢得了邦克山战役，但随后他们不得不撤离波士顿。从某种意义上说，赢得一场战斗是不够的。
Dominic, in that really up until now, the irony is that the King hasn't been a major player. And obviously he's not really in control of government policy. He can only implement things through the cabinet. And he's extremely conscious of constitutional prerogatives and precedents. But he really does very, very, very strongly believe that the Americans should not be allowed to become independent. And so he works very, very hard to basically put some backbone into his cabinet ministers. So he is a factor there. So the issue for the British, how on earth are they going to get America back? Because they won the Battle of Bunker Hill, but then they had to evacuate Boston. So in a sense, winning a battle isn't enough.
你占领了多少领土，你就有多大实力。因此，问题在于，他们能制定什么战略，使他们能够超越沿海那几个零星的据点向外扩张？因此，纽约基本上成为了他们寄托希望的焦点。是这样吗？是的。对于他们能采取什么战略这个问题，其中一个答案是：他们可以摧毁华盛顿的军队，即大陆军。
You are only as good as the territory you're holding. And therefore, the question is, what strategy can they put in that would enable them to expand beyond the few kind of toeholds that they have along the coast? And so New York becomes basically the kind of the focus for their hopes. Is that right? Yes. One answer to the question of what strategy they can do is that they could destroy Washington's army, the Continental Army.
他们本可以做到，而且他们实际上本可以做到。我的意思是，（你知道的）这个故事中的“如果”之一就是，在 1776 年和 1777 年战争初期确实存在这样一些时刻，豪将军和克林顿将军——该地区的两位主要军事指挥官——本可以切断并消灭大陆军，甚至有可能俘虏乔治三世。如果真的发生了这种情况，战争的整个进程可能会看起来极其不同。众所周知，他们本可以阻止大陆军从曼哈顿撤离，但他们没有这样做。他们没有这样做有非常充分的理由，基于后勤、补给等等。但尽管如此，华盛顿还是得以逃脱。但那是一个关键时刻，对吧，
And they could have, and they actually could have done so. I mean, you know, one of the what-ifs in this story is that there were moments early in the war in 1776 and 1777 anyway, when General Howe and General Clinton, who were the two key military commanders in that region, could potentially have cut off the Continental Army and destroyed it, potentially even captured George Washington. And the whole course of the war could have looked extreme, could have looked very different if that had happened. I mean, famously, they could perhaps have prevented the Continental Army from evacuating from Manhattan, and they didn't do so. And there are very good reasons why they didn't do so, based on logistics and supply and so on. But nevertheless, Washington was able to escape. But that's a key moment, isn't it,
亚当？因为他们在斯塔滕岛登陆了。他们在长岛爆发了一场大战，我认为这是战争中规模最大的一场单一战役，结果是英国人获胜。华盛顿的一半军队被困在了布鲁克林。然后英国人犹豫了。他们犹豫的一个原因其实要回到我刚才——我想是汤姆——早些时候说过的话上。
Adam? Because they had landed at Staten Island. They have this huge battle on Long Island, which I think is the biggest single battle of the war, which puts the British win. Half of Washington's army is left trapped in Brooklyn. And then the British hesitate. And one reason they hesitate is actually going back to something that Tom, I think, said earlier on,
亚当？因为他们在史坦顿岛登陆。他们在长岛进行了一场巨大的战役，我认为这是战争中规模最大的一次单场战役，这让英国人获胜了。华盛顿的一半军队被困在布鲁克林。然后英国人犹豫了。他们犹豫的一个原因其实可以追溯到汤姆刚才说过的一些话，
which is that a lot of the British commanders are actually quite ambivalent about the whole business. So General Howe, his brother is Admiral Howe, who's in charge of the Navy, and he used to play chess with Benjamin Franklin when they're in London. So they're all quite sort of sympathetic to the Americans. Yes, they'd all opposed most of this legislation we've been talking about in previous episodes, all of these people. I mean, it's amazing. Yeah. Yeah. They didn't really want the British to to be in this situation even general cornwallis who's famous later on he had opposed he voted against the stamp act yeah incredibly um but anyway they have a peace conference on staten island don't they
也就是说，许多英国指挥官对整件事情其实都相当矛盾。所以豪将军，他的兄弟是海军司令豪勋爵，他以前在伦敦时常跟本杰明·富兰克林下国际象棋。所以他们对美国人其实都挺同情的。是的，他们其实都反对我们在前面节目中讨论过的绝大多数立法，所有这些人。我的意思是，这太让人惊叹了。没错。是的。他们其实并不希望英国人陷入这种境地，甚至连后来大名鼎鼎的康沃利斯将军也都曾反对过，他甚至投票反对过《印花税法案》，是的，真是难以置信。嗯，不管怎样，他们在史泰登岛开了一场和平会议，不是吗？
they meet john adams and benjamin franklin yeah who meets his old chess sparring partner on staten island and the british say to listen, let's just shake hands and pretend this was all a bad dream. Then they basically say the King will pardon you. But the Americans, is it just they're too far gone now? Well, the Americans have already declared independence. From their point of view now, the only terms for peace will be recognition of American independence. And that, of course, is not something that the British military commanders are authorized or would have wanted to concede even if they had been authorized to do so. So it goes nowhere. But could, I mean, if George III had been a tyrant and the British had been the monsters
他们会见了约翰·亚当斯和本杰明·富兰克林。是的，本杰明·富兰克林在史泰登岛见到了他的老棋友。英国人说：“听着，我们握手言和吧，就当这一切只是一场噩梦。”然后他们基本上说国王会赦免你们。但美国人，难道是因为现在事情已经无可挽回了吗？嗯，美国人当时已经宣布独立了。从他们的角度来看，现在唯一的和平条件就是承认美国的独立。当然，这是英国军事指挥官们无权接受的，即便他们获得了授权，也不会愿意接受。所以谈判毫无进展。但是，我的意思是，如果乔治三世是个暴君，而英国人就像
from a Mel Gibson film, presumably they would have just captured or killed the American delegates then and there, destroyed Washington's army, captured or killed him. And we'd be talking about a very different scenario, would we? I mean, do they have the capacity to do that though, Adam? Could they ravage the countryside, take all the towns? Could they do that? Do they have the capacity as in, do they have the military capacity or do they have the will? I mean, they don't have the will as you've been saying and so that's never really a realistic option i mean there are some hotheads in london and some pamphlet writers editorial writers who start suggesting this kind of strategy in the daily mail
梅·吉布森电影里的那些怪物一样，想必他们当时就会直接抓捕或杀死美国代表，摧毁华盛顿的军队，抓住并干掉他。那样的话，我们今天讨论的就会是一个完全不同的剧本了，对吧？我的意思是，他们当时有这个能力吗，亚当？他们能蹂躏乡间、攻占所有城镇吗？他们能做到吗？他们有这个能力吗——我是指军事能力，还是说他们有这个意愿？我的意思是，正如你刚才所说，他们根本没有这个意愿，所以这从来都不是一个现实的选项。我是说，伦敦有一些激进分子、一些撰写小册子的政论家和社论作家，开始在《每日邮报》上鼓吹这种战略。
i was just actually even as you were speaking i was thinking 1200 words i could bang that out by four o'clock. But the weird thing is that you absolutely get the sense the British have already lost this war, that lots of the commanders already feel that they're too ambivalent, that things are going, you know, they don't really have a prospect of it. But at the same time, the Americans feel that they've lost the war. So, you know, they're kind of moaning the game is pretty nearly up. And famously, the kind of the crisis point game is pretty nearly up and famously the kind of the crisis point is when washington finds himself on the wrong side of the river delaware to and this is kind of the end of this coming towards the end of december loads of his troops are going to
其实就在你说话的时候，我还在想：1200字，我四点钟之前就能赶出来。但诡异的是，你绝对能感觉到英国人其实已经输掉了这场战争，许多指挥官已经觉得他们自己的态度太矛盾了，事情的进展……你知道的，他们根本看不到什么胜算。但与此同时，美国人也觉得自己快把这场战争打输了。所以，你知道的，他们有点在哀叹大势已去。而且众所周知，那种危机点的到来，当华盛顿发现自己身处特拉华河的对岸，而这差不多是12月底快要结束的时候，他的大批军队即将……
due to kind of you know their commissions kind of are up at the end of december so he feels that he has to do some kind of stunt that will raise morale and so he he goes back across the delaware that's my summary of one of the most famous episodes of washington crossing the delaware he does and he and he you're right you can see it on her on her back and that kind of fighting spirit attracts the attention of European courts. And together with the British defeat at Saratoga, which is to come in 1777, convinces European powers that the American rebels need backing. Well, before we get to Saratoga, just on the Delaware. So the
由于他们的服役期在12月底就要到期了，所以他觉得自己必须搞点能振奋士气的名堂出来。于是他再次渡过特拉华河——这就是我对华盛顿渡过特拉华河这一最著名事件之一的总结。他确实这么做了，而且你也看到了，这种战斗精神吸引了欧洲宫廷的注意。再加上英国在萨拉托加遭遇惨败（这将发生在1777年），这就说服了欧洲列强，让他们觉得这些美国叛军是需要得到支持的。不过，在我们谈到萨拉托加之前，先说说特拉华河的事。所以
British had ended up capturing Manhattan after the failure of the talks at Staten Island. Washington had then escaped to New Jersey and then gone further south and crossed the River Delaware. And actually, to add to what Tom was saying, he'd had 19,000 men and now he's only got 3,000 men. So he's a real, I mean, maybe sometimes people overstate the ragtagness, if that's a word, of the Continental Army, but they are pretty ragtag. Yes, with huge problems of supply. Yeah, I mean, he's very upfront. He needs to raise the spirits of the people.
在史泰登岛的和谈破裂后，英国人最终攻占了曼哈顿。华盛顿随后逃往新泽西，接着继续向南挺进并渡过了特拉华河。事实上，补充一下汤姆刚才的话，他当时原本有19000人，而现在只剩下3000人了。所以他确实——我的意思是，有时候人们可能夸大了大陆军的乌合之众属性（如果这个词存在的话），但他们确实是一群乌合之众。是的，而且面临着巨大的后勤补给问题。是的，我的意思是，他非常坦诚。他需要重振人民的士气。
Yeah. And this is when Tom Paine writes another of his pamphlets, doesn't he? These are the toimes that Troy men souls, he says in The American Crisis. Which is a good phrase. It is a great, he's a good phrase maker. I mean, like Jefferson, they're terrible people, but they're very good phrase makers. And then Washington does this thing where he strikes across the Delaware on Boxing Day, Christmas night, is it? Standing up, looking very noble with a flag behind him.
是的。也就是在这个时候，托马斯·潘恩写了另一本小册子，不是吗？他在《美国危机》中写道：“这是考验人类灵魂的时刻。”这真是一个好短语。这确实很棒，他很擅长创造金句。就像杰斐逊一样，他们虽然人品糟糕，但都非常擅长金句。然后华盛顿做了一件事，他在节礼日（也就是圣诞节当晚）突袭了特拉华河，是这样吗？他当时挺身站着，显得非常高贵，身后还飘扬着一面旗子。
Is that the painting? Yes, it's a famous painting that apparently got destroyed in the Second World War. By who? By the British, ironically, in a bombing raid. It was in Bre bremen the bremen kunsthalle was it really so it was destroyed in 1942 but hold on it still exists though doesn't it i thought what are the images of it that you see on the internet uh it's i suppose copies photo of it yeah okay all right fair enough so to get back to his attack so it's christmas night
就是那幅画吗？是的，这是一幅著名的画，据说在第二次世界大战中被毁了。被谁？讽刺的是，是被英国人在一次轰炸中炸毁的。当时它在不来梅，是不来梅美术馆吗？真的吗？所以它在1942年被毁了。不过等等，它现在不是依然存在吗？我以为……你在互联网上看到的那些它的画像是怎么回事？呃，我想那应该是复制品或者照片吧。好吧，好吧，那就说得通了。所以回到他的进攻上来，那是圣诞节的夜晚，
and he attacks and actually what's interesting is. So it's Christmas night and he attacks. And actually what's interesting is he attacks as a surprise attack. He has to do it. This great coup d'etat. He attacks a camp that is described as the Hessian camp. So the British have pitched up with a load of German auxiliaries, what Americans would call the mercenaries, from Hesse in particular. And this is, am I right in thinking, Adam,
他发起了进攻。其实有趣的是……所以那是圣诞节的夜晚，他发动了进攻。事实上，有趣的是，这是一场突袭。他必须这么做。这真是一场伟大的奇袭。他袭击了一个被称为黑森佣兵营地的营地。当时英国人带了一大批德国辅助部队过来——美国人称之为雇佣兵，具体来说是来自黑森地区。那么，我这样想对吗，亚当？
that the Americans see this as an absolutely terrible act of betrayal, that the British have brought all these Germans with them? They do. It was a perfectly natural thing to do. I don't want to dig in in defending the British government, but of course, the king was also the elector of Hanover. It seemed a perfectly natural thing to do to find troops from his other domains in Europe. That was was the way that British army always fought wars was by, you know, they were a great naval power fighting land-based campaigns always required using troops from other countries. I mean, the King wrote to Catherine the Great, hoping that she would send Russian troops that probably would have wound up the Americans even more. And the American army themselves, of course, also used auxiliaries, including some from German troops, by the end of the war.
美国人认为这是绝对极其可耻的背叛行为，因为英国人把这些德国人带到了他们这里？他们的确这么觉得。但这其实是一件再自然不过的事情。我可不是想为英国政府辩护，但当然了，国王同时也是汉诺威的选帝侯。从他在欧洲的其他领地寻找军队，这看起来是一件再自然不过的事情。英国军队打仗历来就是这样——你知道的，他们作为一支伟大的海军力量去进行陆上战役，总是需要从其他国家调集军队。我的意思是，国王曾写信给叶卡捷琳娜大帝，希望她能派遣俄国军队，而这可能会彻底激怒美国人。当然，美国军队自己到战争结束时也使用过辅助部队，其中包括一些德国军队。
But you're absolutely right that the Hessians have become a kind of byword for the dirty way that the British were fighting this war, or perhaps more to the point, the fact that the Americans believed that the British were treating them as if they were completely outside the pale. And that was what really stung. Right. But then Washington follows that up with another extraordinary coup d'etat. So he reaches Princeton, and then he looks like he's going to attack General Cornwallis' camp, but actually he sort of sneaks around by a back road, attacks Cornwallis' rear guard, I think, takes them by surprise.
但你说得完全没错，黑森雇佣兵已经成了英国人打这场肮脏战争的代名词，或者更确切地说，美国人深信英国人把他们当成了完全不可理喻的野蛮人对待。而这才是真正刺痛他们的地方。没错。但随后华盛顿又发起了另一场非凡的奇袭。他抵达了普林斯顿，看起来像是要去进攻康沃利斯将军的营地，但实际上他从一条小路迂回过去，出其不意地袭击了康沃利斯后卫部队，我想这彻底打了个他们措手不及。
This is at Princeton. And by the time Cornwallis gets there, Washington has outwitted him, attacked his rear guard, and then escaped. And these two together create this image. Cheers everyone up. Well, it cheers everyone. It creates the image of Washington as a tremendous commander. It suggests the Americans haven't lost after all.
这就是普林斯顿战役。等康沃利斯赶到时，华盛顿已经智胜了他，袭击了他的后卫部队，然后成功撤退了。这两场行动结合在一起，塑造了这样的形象。让所有人都振奋起来。嗯，这让所有人都振奋了。它将华盛顿塑造成了一位了不起的统帅。它表明美国人并没有彻底战败。
It sends a message across Europe. And I suppose it makes the stakes for haven't lost after all it sends a message across europe and i suppose it makes the stakes for the british as they enter 1777 much higher and this is where we get back to your hudson valley strategy because they really need this to work don't they and this is burgoyne and how so how is going up from new york isn't it that's the plan and burgoyne will come down from quebec butoyne? So Burgoyne is a... He's a poet. Playwright. His nickname was Gentleman Johnny.
它向整个欧洲发出了信号。我想这也让英国人在进入1777年时面临的赌注变得更高了。这就是我们回到你们所说的“哈德逊河谷战略”的原因，因为他们真的需要这个计划成功，不是吗？这就是伯戈因和豪的计划：豪将军将从纽约北上，对吧，这就是计划，而伯戈因将从魁北克南下。伯戈因？所以伯戈因是一个……他是个诗人。剧作家。他的绰号是“温文尔雅的强尼”。
That doesn't suggest martial vigour. But it's like strike fear in the breasts of his enemies. No, but I think that was because he was so polite to his own troops. Polite? Yes, I think he was very... You know, he treated them very well. Okay. Well, I was going to say, I don't want a polite general. I want a rough,
这听起来可不像有什么尚武的活力。但这会令他的敌人们闻风丧胆吧？不，我想这是因为他对自己的军队非常有礼貌。有礼貌？是的，我想他非常……你知道的，他对手下非常好。好吧。本来我想说，我可不想要一个有礼貌的将军。我想要一个粗鲁、
raucous, hard driving bastard, Tom. No, so he's sitting in his tent writing plays and being polite to his men. Right. I think he was actually quite an able general. And I think he had a sense that basically this strategy, which is him moving southwards, how moving northwards, that it's not going to work. What strikes me about all the British generals in this story is how fundamentally pessimistic they are well i'll tell you a fact about john burgoyne that will make you think very very highly of him he wrote a semi-operatic uh production of a play about richard the lionheart tom and do you know where it was performed in 1788 uh no the drury lane theater can you think
喧闹、强力推进的混蛋，汤姆。不，所以他正坐在帐篷里写剧本，对他的部下彬彬有礼。好吧。我想他其实是一位相当有能力的将军。而且他有一种直觉，基本上觉得这个战略——也就是他向南进军，豪将军向北进军——是不会成功的。在这个故事中，所有英国将军给我留下的最深刻印象，是他们骨子里是多么悲观。好吧，我来告诉你一个关于约翰·伯戈因的事实，这会让你对他的评价发生极大的改观：他曾写过一部关于理查一世的半歌剧性质的戏剧作品，汤姆。你知道它是在哪里上演的吗？在1788年。呃，不知道。德鲁里巷剧院。你能想到
of any other great acts that have played the drury lane theater who have subsequently gone on to invade america the rest is history you and me the rest is history the whole podcast has been leading up to that moment to that moment i can see adam adam is delighted this is the summit of his scholarly career so um so how is going northwards he's going quite well he's he's actually i mean he's kind of outmaneuvering washington i think at this point washington's kind of complaining about this he says that um but he gets distracted doesn't he how yes so washington says of how that he's engaging in a variety of perplexing maneuvers. You don't want someone to say that about you because he ends up taking Philadelphia, which he shouldn't have done.
还有哪个曾上演过德鲁里巷剧院作品的伟大人物后来去入侵了美洲？历史就是由你我书写的，历史就是由你我书写的。整个播客节目一直都在为那一刻、为那一刻做铺垫。我能看出亚当，亚当高兴极了，这是他学术生涯的巅峰。所以呢……所以豪将军正在向北挺进，进展还算顺利。他实际上——我的意思是，我觉得他在此时甚至有点在智胜华盛顿。华盛顿对此有所抱怨，他说……但他分心了，不是吗，豪将军？是的。所以华盛顿评价豪将军说，他正在进行各种令人眼花缭乱的复杂机动。你可不想让别人这么评价你，因为他最后竟然去占领了费城，而他本不该这么做的。
He should have just left Philadelphia alone and gone north, isn't it? Yeah. And meanwhile, Burgoyne is coming south from Canada. He has, I read, 30 carts of personal baggage and a baggage train three miles long. And they're proceeding so slowly, they're going less than a mile a day, which is not the kind of... I mean, that's Gentleman Johnny for you, Tom. He's proceeding at a sort of gentleman's pace instead of rushing, as I would have him do.
他本该放着费城不管直接北上的，对吧？是的。与此同时，伯戈因正从加拿大南下。我看到资料说，他带了30辆装满个人行李的马车，行李辎重队伍长达三英里。他们前进的速度极其缓慢，每天甚至不到一英里，这可不是那种……我的意思是，这就是你的“温文尔雅的强尼”，汤姆。他以一种绅士的步伐慢条斯理地前进，而不是像我希望的那样一路狂飙突进。
And they get to Saratoga in the autumn, and they find a fellow there called General Horatio Gates. I don't know anything about him. Do you know anything about him, Adam? Yeah, he was an Essex lad. Yeah, he was born in Essex. That's the main thing I know about him, Dominic. They're all these Anglians kind of fighting each other.
他们在秋天抵达了萨拉托加，在那里遇到了一位名叫霍雷肖·盖茨将军的人。我对这个人一无所知。你了解他吗，亚当？是的，他是埃塞克斯郡人。是的，他出生在埃塞克斯。这就是我关于他所知道的主要事情了，多米尼克。这些盎格鲁人居然在互相厮杀。
Very odd. So he gets there. So he's already there with the New England militia. Burgoyne gets there, and it's the classic thing. The British are always trying to attack uphill, which seems grossly unfair against people hiding behind trees. Correct. Gates is on a place called Bemis Heights or Bemis Heights.
真的很奇怪。所以他到达了那里。他带着新英格兰民兵已经在那里了。伯戈因也赶到了，这就是经典的一幕：英国人总是试图仰攻山头，在那些藏在树后的人面前，这显得极其不公平。没错。盖茨驻扎在一个叫比米斯高地（Bemis Heights）的地方。
I don't know how you pronounce it. Burgoyne charges up the hill on the 19th of September. 600 of his men shot or wounded. And then he ends up basically trapped. So it's upstate New York, I guess, Adam. Is it Saratoga? This is where they are. He's got no food.
我不知道具体该怎么发音。伯戈因在9月19日带兵冲上山岗。他的部下有600人被击毙或受伤。最后他基本上被困住了。所以那是纽约州北部吧，亚当？就是萨拉托加吗？他们就在那里。他没有食物。
It's pouring with rain. It's very cold. It's very miserable. And the local people have all burned their farmlands, so he can't get any supplies. And he's waiting for the other British army is going to get there. They don't get there. So he has another go on the 7th of October,
大雨倾盆。天气非常冷。情况非常悲惨。当地人都把自己的农田给烧了，所以他根本无法获得任何补给。他一直在等待另一支英国军队赶来。但他们并没有来。所以在10月7日，他又发起了一次进攻。
driven back again by um gates his troops and basically on the 17th of october so 10 days after that after just sort of hanging around freezing starving wet miserable burgoyne surrenders but on good terms right because the thing is that they're not kind of taken away to prison of war camps it's agreed that they can go back to the european theater of war war camps. It's agreed that they can go back to the European theater of war and serve there. It's just that they can't come back to America. So the fact that they go back to Europe means that they can replace troops
再次被盖茨的军队击退。基本上就在10月17日——也就是那之后的10天，在经历了一段时间的四处游荡、忍饥挨饿、冰冷潮湿和极度痛苦之后，伯戈因投降了。但条件很优厚，对吧？因为他们并没有被带去战俘营，双方商定他们可以返回欧洲战区继续服役。只是不能再回到美洲参战。所以他们返回欧洲，就意味着他们可以替换掉那些
that can then be sent to America. And so Gates is, is widely blamed for this. But I suppose the issue though, from the British perspective is they can't keep losing armies. I mean, they can't just keep throwing endless men into the American more as it were well i think i think that it what it shows is is basically that the whole british war effort is is futile essentially they can't leave the atlantic seaboard and go inland without being
随后可以被派往美洲的军队。因此，盖茨为此受到了广泛的指责。但我想，从英国的角度来看，问题在于他们经不起不断失去军队的打击。我的意思是，他们不能就这样把无穷无尽的人填进美洲这个泥潭里，对吧？嗯，我认为……我认为这说明的基本上是，整个英国的战争努力本质上是徒劳的。他们只要离开大西洋沿岸深入内陆，就会遭到
picked off and that's where the kind of the analogy with the vietnam war yeah i think kind of well or any almost any colonial war time actually when you think about it i mean it's striking to me the extent to which i don't know how much you think this is true adam this is a prototype for so many european colonial counter-insurgency campaigns in the 19th 20th centuries jimmy and foo and yeah where you you're desperate trying to pacify the countryside but your troops go inland and then they get cut off and surrounded by gorillas and you know they run out of supplies and all that kind of thing. Do you think that's fair to describe as that? Yes, I do. But I also think, and I think Tom's description of the surrender at Saratoga reinforces this, that the British never really fully embraced that. I mean, they did learn to
各个击破。这就是为什么人们会把它类比为越南战争……是的，我想差不多是这样，或者其实仔细想想，几乎可以类比为任何一场殖民战争。对我来说，最引人注目的是——我不知道你觉得这有多大程度是真实的，亚当——这简直是19、20世纪无数次欧洲殖民反游击战的雏形，吉米和富，是的，在那些战争中，你拼命想要安抚乡村，但你的军队一旦深入内陆，就会被游击队切断退路并包围，你知道的，他们会弹尽粮绝，经历诸如此类的一切。你觉得这样形容公平吗？是的，我确实这么认为。但我也认为——汤姆对萨拉托加投降的描述也加深了这一点——英国人从来没有真正完全接受这一点。我的意思是，他们的确学会了
adapt. I mean, it wasn't that the British generals were just hoping for proper set-piece battles. They did adapt to the realities of a guerrilla conflict, but they never responded in the way that the Americans did in Vietnam, for example, with a kind of scorched earth policy of their own, or only in very occasional circumstances. Usually, it was loyalist partisans rather than the regular British army. Right, and so the fact that Burgoy going as a gentleman is precisely the problem he really is a gentleman yeah um and so this is obviously sends us uh you know shockwaves across europe now the french have already been secretly supplying the americans haven't they yeah i read that the playwright beaumarchais had formed a dummy corporation to send guns and gunpowder to the Americans. And King Louis XVI had actually given them a million livres, again, secretly,
适应。并不是说英国将军们仅仅指望打那些堂堂正正的阵地战。他们确实适应了游击战的现实，但他们从来没有像美国人在越南那样做出回应，例如实行他们自己的焦土政策，或者只在极少数情况下才会这么做。通常是由忠英派民兵而不是正规英军来做这些。没错，所以伯戈因身为一个绅士恰恰是问题所在，他真的是个绅士，是的。嗯，这显然在欧洲各地引发了……你知道的，巨大的震撼波。现在法国人其实已经一直在秘密支援美国人了，对吧？是的，我读到过剧作家博马舍曾成立了一家皮包公司，向美国人运送枪支和火药。路易十六国王实际上还给了他们一百万里弗尔，同样是秘密进行的，
so it couldn't be traced back to him. So the French, all this time, have been basically rooting for the Americans. And I guess, what is it, February 1778, they make that explicit when they declare war. But just before that, Dominic, the most famous French supporter of American freedom is the Marquis de Lafayette, a very young man who, astonishingly, is inspired to go and fight for the Americans by meeting the younger brother of George III, the Duke of Gloucester. He's at a dinner with the Duke of Gloucester and the Duke of Gloucester is going on about how tremendous the American rebels are and how he's on their side, which seems kind of mind-blowing. And if you think of the Duke of Gloucester and Samuel Johnson as kind of different shades of opinion in Britain, it does give you a sense in which there is a kind of ideological civil war going on in Britain at this time. But with the French, Adam, I mean, that's a game changer, right?
所以无法追溯到他身上。所以在这段漫长的时间里，法国人基本上一直在暗中支持美国人。我想，大概在1778年2月，随着他们宣战，这种支持变得明朗化了。但就在这之前，多米尼克，美国自由最著名的法国支持者是拉法耶特侯爵，他当时是一个非常年轻的人。令人惊异的是，他通过结识乔治三世的幼弟格洛斯特公爵，受到了鼓舞，从而去为美国人战斗。他当时和格洛斯特公爵一起参加晚宴，格洛斯特公爵一直在滔滔不绝地讲述美国叛军是多么伟大，以及他是如何站在他们一边 的，这听起来简直太令人震撼了。如果你把格洛斯特公爵和塞缪尔·约翰逊看作英国不同政治光谱的代表，这确实让你感觉到当时英国国内正在进行一场意识形态的内战。但对于法国人来说，亚当，我的意思是，这彻底改变了游戏规则，对吧？
It's a complete game changer. Lafayette was far from being the only European military adventurer to go and join the American cause. He becomes the famous one, doesn't he? Because basically he becomes Washington's adopted son. He does. And they loved him because he offered to fight for no pay and he was willing to serve in the ranks rather than just expecting to be given a commission, as most of them did straight away. And also because this because he really did believe in it. And so he became a hugely important figure as a validation of the universal significance of what the Americans were fighting for, as well as for the military expertise that he and others
这完全改变了游戏规则。拉法耶特远非唯一一个前往并加入美国事业的欧洲军事冒险家。但他成了最著名的一个，不是吗？因为他基本上成了华盛顿的养子。他的确如此。他们爱戴他，因为他提出不要任何薪水来参战，而且他愿意从普通士兵做起，而不是像大多数人那样一去就指望被授予军官军衔。还因为——因为他是真的深信不疑。因此，他成为一个极其重要的人物，不仅证明了美国人所为具有普遍的重大意义，而且也带来了他和其他人所具备的
brought. So that sort of sense the whole world is watching, shot heard around the world, all that sort of stuff. He bears that out, I suppose suppose and so with the french entrance to the war presumably for britain now you know the american colonists they're not neither here nor there but the absolute priority now is we can't lose huge tracts of air you know we can't lose the sugar islands we can't we don't want to you lose um gibraltar yeah gibraltar you know these sort of i don't know minorca those kinds of places yeah and india they don't want to lose Gibraltar, Menorca, those kinds of places. Yeah, and India. They don't want to lose ground in India to the French. And Canada as well.
军事专业知识。所以那种“全世界都在瞩目”、“响彻世界的枪声”之类的感觉，我想他确实印证了这一点。因此，随着法国参战，对于英国来说——现在的局势是，美洲殖民地倒还在其次，当务之急绝对是：我们不能失去广袤的土地——你知道的，我们不能失去糖岛，我们不能失去……我们不想失去直布罗陀。是的，直布罗陀，你知道的，诸如此类的小地方。是的，还有印度。他们不想在印度向法国人失势。还有加拿大也是。
I mean, those parts of North America, which is, say, Canada and Florida at this point, that are not engaged in rebellion. Right. So the war now enters a completely new phase. Indeed, the American Revolution enters a new phase. And I think we should probably call a halt here for those of you who are not members of the Restless History Club. Of course, if you are, the tremendous news is you just keep listening because Adam will
我的意思是，北美那些当时并未卷入叛乱的部分，也就是当时的加拿大和佛罗里达。没错。所以战争现在进入了一个全新的阶段。确切地说，美国革命进入了一个全新的阶段。我想我们现在应该在这里暂停一下，对于那些还不是“历史其余部分”俱乐部会员的听众朋友们。当然，如果你已经是会员了，有个好消息：你们只需继续收听，因为亚当将在
be with you in seconds talking about the final stages of the war, the surrender at Yorktown, and the beginnings of the peacetime American Republic. So you'll be back with all that, won't you, Adam? You're looking forward to it? I certainly will. I'm looking forward to that. Yeah. Tremendous.
几秒钟后与你们见面，谈论战争的最后阶段、约克敦的投降，以及和平时期美洲共和国的萌芽。所以你将会带着所有这些内容回归，对吧，亚当？你很期待吗？我当然很期待。我很期待那个。是的。太棒了。
Been fun so far. Very sad. Tom's not looking forward to it, which is, Tom's doing it under duress. Presumably this whole series has been a trauma for you, has it, Tom?
到目前为止很有趣。非常遗憾。汤姆并不期待，也就是说，汤姆是在勉强完成这件事。想必这一整个系列对你来说都是一场心理创伤吧，汤姆？
Yeah, it's very traumatic. But let's hope it hasn't been traumatic for everybody else. And on that bombshell, we'll say thank you very much. See you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. and on that bombshell we'll say thank you very much see you next time bye bye bye bye
是的，这非常具有创伤性。但愿这对其他人来说不是一场创伤。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们要说非常感谢大家。下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们要说非常感谢大家。下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。
thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家放送的额外节目、抢先收听特权、无广告收听体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论以及一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
额外节目以及抢先获得现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。